is it still possible
for a person who's a black ball to to
then just go back to that beginning
journey i guess
of course let me tell you something
i'm probably going to catch a lot of
flak for saying this i have a belief
i won't say something i won't call it
knowledge because it's not known but i
have a fervent belief
the human beings in
most skill activities not all skill
activities but i will say combat sports
for sure can reinvent themselves in five
year
periods now you might be saying
five years what's magical about five
years
mike tyson was 13 years old when he was
taken in by customarto
by the age of 18 he was beating
world-class boxers in the gym and had
already made a
a strong name for himself in
international boxing he's already a
known figure
it was five years
yasiro yamashita the judo player
began judo at 13.
he placed silver in the old japans
at 17.
i could go on all day with examples
of athletes who within a
five-year time frame of starting a sport
were competing at world championship
level i'm going to give you
a rough and ready definition of sport
mastery
okay i believe that if you can play
a competitive match against someone
ranked
in the top 25 in your sport
and it's a serious international sport i
would call you someone who's mastered
that sport
okay you you're damn good um
if you can go with the number 25
wrestler in the world
and give them a hard competitive match
in the gym you may not win it but
you know they had a good workout you
have
shown mastery of wrestling
or indeed any other combat sport you
care to name
there are numerous examples of people
doing far better than that
in five years winning
medals at world championships and even
olympic games in that five-year period
this is not an unrealistic goal there is
a lot of empirical evidence to show that
people have done this in the past a lot
of it
so if you fully immerse yourself in a
sport
with a well worked out well-planned
training program there is a mountain of
evidence to show that in a five-year
period
you can go from
a complete beginner to a
very very impressive skill level to the
point where you're competitive with some
of the best people on the planet
you can reinvent yourself in these
five-year periods
what happens with most people is they
get to a certain level and they get
complacent they get lazy
and they just keep doing the same old
thing they've been doing
but if you're diligent and you're
purposeful
five years you can accomplish an awful
lot and as i said there's a mountain of
evidence to show it
by the way as a small aside somebody
who's mentioned taversky and yamashita
in the same conversation you're one of
the most impressive people i've ever
spoken to
but it's that's a small side uh
so if if there's this complete beginner
this is really interesting
there is empirical evidence that you can
achieve incredible things in a short
amount of time
there's a complete beginner standing
before you
and that beginner has fire in their eyes
and they want to achieve mastery
where do you place most of the credit
for it for a journey that does achieve
mastery
is it the set of ideas they have in
their mind
is it the the set of drills or the way
they practice
is it genetics and luck
those are all good insights all of those
factors you've mentioned
play a definite role let's start with
luck okay
we are all subject to fortune
and fortune can be good and fortune can
be bad
life is in many ways beautiful but life
is also tragic
and i've had students who showed
enormous promise and just tragic events
occurred in their lives
the vicitudes of fortune can be
a wonderful thing in your life and they
can be a a terrible tragedy
um i've had students who who died uh
for various reasons who could have gone
on to become world champions
i've had students who uh on a much
lighter note just
fell in love and just wanted to have
kids and move away and
that's that's a that's a wonderful thing
but different direction
um you just never know so luck does
play some role um even things like where
you're born
uh the location of your physical
location in the world or even the
socio-economic location can
can play a role which could be
detrimental or favorable
so yet luck does play some role
thankfully it's one of the smaller
elements
and i do believe that a truly
resourceful mind can overcome
the majority of what fortune throws at
us
and and get two goals provided you're
sufficiently mentally robust
other things you mentioned genetics
[Music]
i do believe in certain sports genetics
really do
play a powerful powerful role for
example in any sport where
power output and reaction speed
ability to take physical damage then
there are genetic
elements which will help okay for
example
i couldn't imagine a world in which even
if
i i have a crippled leg so even if i uh
grew up in a world where my leg was was
normal and i had normal legs and
everything was fine with my body i don't
believe
that i could win the olympic gold medal
in 100 meter sprinting for example okay
i just don't have enough
fast twitch muscle fibers but the more
a sport involves skill and tactics
the less you will see genetics playing a
role
if you look at the middle podiums in jiu
jitsu for example
you will see that no one body type
is definitively superior to another you
will see
every variation of body type and the
metal platforms and jujitsu
as skill and tactics become more and
more important and things like just
power output over time become less and
less important
then you will see that genetics play
less and less of a role i'm i'm happy to
say that the sport of jitter2
the evidence seems pretty clear that
there's no one dominant body type in a
sport of judas so rather there's just
advantages for one type and there's
advantages for another
you just have to learn to tailor your
game to your body
with regards to training program yes i
believe with all my heart and all my
soul
that your training program does make a
difference i've dedicated my life to
that obviously i'm biased
in this regard i do believe that all of
the students that i taught
who became world champions would have
been great athletes whether or not they
had met me or not
i believe that but i do also believe it
would have taken them a lot longer and
they may not have gotten to the level
that they did they
i'm sure they would have been impressive
but i do believe
that the nature of a training program
plays an enormous difference
i don't mean to say this in an arrogant
way i believe that
there's again a mountain of evidence to
suggests this is true because you see it
in many different sports
let's talk for example about your
country
russia and its wrestling program
russia is an enormous country but the
location
where russia's wrestling program comes
from is actually very small
and the population is actually very
small i can't
verify this but i was told once i can't
verify this but the number of people who
wrestle in russia is actually
significantly smaller
than the number of people who wrestle in
the united states it's also not part of
the
school uh uh athletics and it is in the
united states yes
that's a different point we'll come back
to right to that because that's also an
important point
but if you look at the actual numbers of
people there they're actually pretty
small
so ostensibly if it comes down to a
numbers game america should dominate at
the olympics if we have more wrestlers
now this the story gets more complicated
because america has a different style of
wrestling the collegiate style than the
international freestyle that
is a complicating factor um
but nonetheless uh what you see there
is that numbers on everything rather
the manner in which people are trained
clearly has an impact
and we know very little about the this
very little reliable information about
the training program for wrestling
in uh in the russian states
but one thing is incontestable is the
amount of success that they've had in
international world championship and
olympic competition
they are disproportionately successful
despite their relatively small numbers
there's nothing genetically special
about them
um you can talk about performance
enhancing drugs but those are a
worldwide phenomenon
they don't have any access to technology
that the rest of the world doesn't have
at some point you've got to start asking
what are they doing differently in the
training room
and there are many other examples
of similar situations my country new
zealand
has an insanely
successful rugby program the sport of
rugby
which they have dominated for
literally generations despite the fact
that our population is
very very small compared with the rest
of the country and we don't excel in
many other sports
it's new zealand does fairly well and
sports overall but nothing like they do
in rugby um
and you've got to ask yourself is there
a culture there which
built this up and the world is full of
examples
of seemingly small and unpromising
areas or locations putting out
disproportionately high
numbers of successful athletes
and that points to the idea that
different training programs
have different success rates and so i
truly believe with all my heart and all
my soul
that how you train does make a
significant difference
i would even go further and say it makes
the most difference is it the only thing
absolutely not we've already talked
about fortune we've talked about
genetics
uh if you want to get nasty you can even
talk about things like performance
enhancing drugs that obviously plays a
role in modern sports
um uh but i do believe
that the majority of uh
of what creates success is the
interaction between the athlete and the
training program
now the training program is one thing i
i do believe that's the single most
important but
right behind it is the athlete
themselves okay
um in my own experience uh people
talk about athletes that i've trained
successfully but they never talk about
athletes that i've trained
unsuccessfully
um always remember that for every
champion a coach producers there's a
hundred people that they coach that
no one ever heard of and this is
completely normal a coach can never take
the lion's share of the credit the coach
creates possibilities but it's the
athlete who
actualizes the possibilities and so
building that rapport
and finding the right people to excel in
your training program is also a big part
of it
you